und jetzt sei klar dass sie das jetzt
mit reingenommen haben erhöht was geht
ab und bekommen bei einem neuen video
hier mal wieder auf einem kanal und so
ich habe hier von einem gewissen
zeitraum mal dieses video gemacht dinge
die mädchen an jungs nicht verstehen und
das ist echt mega cool bei euch
angekommen
deswegen habe ich mir für heute
überlegen ja komm machte davon doch
einfach mal den zweiten teil und ja ich
habe vor so ein kleines format aus
diesen dinge die dann halt immer mit
mädchen und jungs irgendwie im
zusammenhang
irgendwie so ein format daraus zu machen
falls euch das gefällt schreibt in die
kommentare oder so ansonst jetzt viel
spaß mit dem video und die roboter
rheine und dann würde ich mal sagen wir
fangen an mit nummer eins und zwar kennt
die mädchen das so bestimmt wenn ihr
gerade mal so einen jungen anschreibt
und gefragt ob er heute vielleicht mal
zeit hat um der antwort tut mir leid ich
muss fußball gucken so war es bei mir
zumindest vor zwei tagen bei einer
gewissen personen die sich jetzt
bestimmt angesprochen fühlt auf jeden
fall was da noch auf die wm bezogen die
ja wirklich nur alle vier jahre ist und
diese person hat dann geschrieben ja du
interessiert sich für fußball und ich
für mich und so was halt aber ich meine
wenn jetzt gerade mal so die wm ist und
ich meine hier ist ja wirklich nur alle
vier jahre dann ist es doch klar dass
man das jetzt auch mal gucken will wenn
man gerne fußball mag oder nicht wie
mein fühlt euch nicht jetzt sogleich ihr
ja der junge mag euch nicht oder so habe
ich auf jeden fall nicht ganz verstanden
und jetzt mitten im klar dass sie das
jetzt mit reingenommen haben
naja und dann kommen wir auch schon zu
punkt 2 und zwar wundert ihr euch einmal
darüber bzw
er regt euch darüber auf also ihr
mädchen warum jetzt 99 prozent aller
jungen justin bieber nicht mögen
beziehungsweise sagen sie würden ihn
überhaupt nicht mögen dazu kann ich aber
erstmal sagen dass ich jetzt diese
meinung also dass der junge justin
bieber überhaupt nicht mag auf jeden
fall im laufe des älterwerdens ändert
also hab ich jetzt mitbekommen als ich
13 war hat auch wieder gesagt ne yos
universe voll scheiße und die hälfte
wusste nicht mehr wer das ist also war
bei mir zumindest so und jetzt bin ich
16 und dann sagen auch relativ viele ja
ich höre auch uns humanit von dem und
ich finde es auch gar nicht mehr so
scheiße also ich weiß dass ganz viele
die jetzt gerade dieses video schauen so
zwischen 13
jetzt zehn jahre alt sind und ihr habt
bestimmt ganz viele jungen die auch so
neuer weiter noch sind und wir sagen ja
just me by scheiße mal so ein kleiner
tipp von mir wir es hat doch fast jeder
person heutzutage spotify erfolg gehen
da noch einfach mal und dann schaut mal
so ab und zu rein was jetzt gerade
gehört haben und ich glaub da kommt auch
relativ oft justin bieber auf rechts
zieht dann doch einfach mal drauf an und
ihr werdet ihr sehen was sie sagen dann
sagen sie wahrscheinlich einmal das neue
lied allein oder soll bestimmt nicht ja
und dann kommen wir jetzt auch schon zu
punkt 3 und zwar ist das so eine sache
die passiert mir persönlich zu zeit
irgendwie jede woche ein bis zwei mal
und zwar ist es ja klar wenn man
youtuber ist dann wird man auch ab und
zu darauf angesprochen und das ist bei
mit zurzeit ziemlich oft der fall so
unter ja dann kommen halt ab und zu auch
mal mädchen und die frage bleiben ja ich
finde das eigentlich ganz cool was du da
machst aber ich verstehe gar nicht wie
du dir das haus war ich persönlich würde
mir das niemals trauen weil ich gar
nicht weiß wie meine freundin darauf
reagieren ob ich dann ausgelacht werde
weil die videos scheiße sind oder
irgendeine kerngehalt ja dann fragen
auch viele dazu ob das jetzt so daran
liegt dass ich ein junge bin und dass
mir nur deswegen traue wo ich dann auch
denke was ist da wo ist da bitte der
sinn ich meine es gibt zwar viel mehr
jungen als mädchen auf youtube aber ich
spiele jetzt glaube ich keine rolle ob
man jetzt weiblich oder männlich ist und
ja deswegen checke ich das nicht so ganz
also wenn du da jetzt ein mädchen wissen
ungefähr genau so denkst dann wird mich
auf jeden fall mal interessieren warum
er ausgerechnet so denken also schreibt
das doch mal bitte einfach in die
kommentare das würde ich echt übel gerne
mal wissen wollte ich verstehe es ihnen
überhaupt nicht und dann befinden wir
uns jetzt auch leider schon wieder so
ziemlich am ende dieses videos ist
vielleicht ein bisschen kürzer geraten
als sonst auf jeden fall geht es auch
nächste woche mit pop oder so direkt
weiter mit einem kleinen text ja auch
wieder online kommt jetzt hier auch
keine ahnung
auf jeden fall hoffe es hat euch
gefallen und wenn ihr mir mit diesen
drei punkten recht gibt dann würd mich
freuen wenn ihr einfach mal daumen nach
oben da das und japan ihr nicht
vergessen wenn ihr nichts mehr verpassen
danke für echt krass 5000 abonnenten an
euch alle haben mich riesig gefreut und
nun in der infobox sind aber links zu
instagram und co verlieren könnt ihr
auch folgen ansonsten geht es hier unten
links jetzt weiter mit diesem
teil von dinge die mädchen jungs nicht
verstehen und hier unten rechts mit dem
ersten teil von dinge die mädchen an
jungs nicht verstehen
die dinge die jungs ein mädchen ich
hoffe ihnen so rumpelt auf jeden fall jo
wir sehen uns dann im laufe der nächsten
woche ich wünsche euch noch ein
traumhaftes wochenende und hört rein